en l'honneur de la spa on a voulu ce
soir je vous dis vous montrer les vidéos
les plus rigolotes des animaux et quand
vous allez voir ces vidéos vous allez
dire plus jamais j'abandonnerai un
animal c'est le top 20 des vidéo
d'arcade nos amis des bêtes
alors je sais pas si vous le savez mais
les mouettes ça ne fait pas que faire
caca sur les pare-brise en normandie
ça vole également dans les supermarchés
c'est le numéro 20 regarde
[Musique]
lassé des vidéos mignonne et je les
reconnais c'est pas du tout ça va vous
avez vu cette mode qui voilà qui voilà
donc d'abord en 19e j'ai un point commun
avec les moutons je vous le dis on aime
la bagarre alors mais lui c'est le
mouton le plus keira de l'histoire des
moutons regardez un mouton qui
s'embrouille avec tout le monde je la
regarde
[Musique]
voilà alors je veux qu'elle soit tout le
monde va bien mais les voilà il a il
était très génère mais il s'est calmé le
mouton voilà je vous le dis et tous les
gens qui sont dans cette vidéo vont bien
voilà c'est un mouton qui est un petit
peu énervé c'est en fait c'est le bouton
de gilles verdez il était en débat voilà
il est un peu énervé en dix-huitième
incertain pendant le confinement ils
peuvent pas du tout sortir ils ont
raison et même quand il faut sortir les
chiens ont une technique regarder quand
il faut sortir leurs chiens ils ont une
technique regarde et la maaf avait
tellement la flemme de sens hier son
chien alors vous dit le chien n'est pas
du tout étranger pascal amiens à redire
mais c'est donc voilà et il est temps qu
est-ce que vous sortez votre chien vous
pendant cette période de confinement
kasumi dormi trois quatre fois par jour
pas longtemps parce que j'ai pas envie
j'ai fait mais j'avoue de remplir à
chaque fois le formulaire parce que dans
le formulaire tout est logique celle de
combat rend visite à quelqu'un en plus
professionnels on ne sait pas ça se voit
pas quand promènent leur chien ça soit
mais chez des petits tours je reste 5
minutes et plusieurs fois cinq minutes
alors en dix septième position je vous
dis je suis tombé sur une vidéo
je savais pas que les irak les girafes
les girafes sont très chaudes
je vous le dis je sais pas si vous êtes
déjà sorti avec une girafe et regarder
fois les girafes sont chaudes regard des
salariés reconnaissaient
[Musique]
franchement cette vidéo me gêne cette
vidéo me gêne d'ouvrir l'esprit cette
vidéo nos gènes
voilà sachez que ça n'est pas sophie la
girafe un pour les enfants mais cette
vidéo me gêne un peu voilà non mais
c'est vrai quoi jean michel calvez toi
quand même un s'il te plaît alors on se
dit oh en 16e position après le chien
qui balance on a le chien qui chante du
rail regardez on achète bulldogs c'est
en deuxième position du top des animaux
[Musique]
c'est celle bolbec dû faire ça les
connaît il est exceptionnel c'est
bulldogs je suis pas il fait partie des
trois soleils sa page à massat a fait
kiffer vous aider et appuyer des belles
comme ça on pense qu'elles pas mais pas
du tout c'est magique
j'adore c'est ses sublimes franchement
de sa vie ça me régale les jeunes
adorent alors oui sophy mon chien parle
que vous voulez que je ne pas se parler
oui mais bon bah oui malaisie mais
maintenant la chance que je la prépare
un minimum elle bardoulat très bas
préparer la paix vous nous direz je vous
prierais à chaque fois qu'on va au zoo
je vous dis j'ai remarqué quelque chose
moi c'est que quand il ya des singes les
singes
je sais pas s'ils font ça pour nous
énerver il nous montre tout le temps
leurs fesses je passe mona et il se
retourne comme ça et on leur fait j'en
vois là j'en arrive à nous narguer un
peu les choses mais non marquées ou pas
et bien regardez niçois c'est chelou
ouais c'est vrai
mathieu c'est vrai tu fais pareil
regardez
[Musique]
vas-y que ça rigolait il est souple à
une soupe lettre à quoi le numéro 14
normalement quand tu vas à la pêche est
tranquille sauf que là le maire un
poisson il l'a mis en angoisse de ouf
regardez bien ce poisson là angoissé et
je peux le comprendre garde
[Musique]
c'est bien
la soie mais vous imaginez moi si ça
m'arrive je deviens ou faisant rigoler
mais après j'ai recherché le poisson
faire je sens en loge de la wii avec
tous les poissons dans l'eau c'est toi
qui m'as besoins ses doigts qui marque
de baskets
non mais franchement et ça doit
surprendre c'est sinon moi c'est moi et
gg je vous le dis moi j'ai fait regarder
les dents de la mer
j'ai faim je fous j'ai fait regarder les
dents de la mer à mes enfants et je peux
vous dire j'étais la plus grosse erreur
de vision 8 et 9 ans aurait jamais eu
parce que non parce que sur la sur le
truc qui disent ouais c'est c'est pour
tout public
mais en fait je m'en veux dire ça fond
ça fait flipper diouf en fait pas du
tout pour tout public
au treizième position je devais montrer
une vidéo très très très mignonne c'est
un canard qui est mort de rire
apparemment voilà il est au spectacle de
bouder en tout cas pas celui de jean
michel c'est sûr je les regarde sans
fois cette vidéo regardez
[Musique]
[Rires]
il est bon le canard mois les et canard
ça me fait peur j'ai toujours peur qu'un
canard mordent avec son mec c'est
méchant carapace ouais si méchant
apparemment les policiers mettant le
doigt les douanes les arts allait
charger les toits moi je connaissais que
leur père jean michel andré sur en 12e
position très très loin au deuxième
position vous connaissez la rumeur selon
laquelle à la manne crache dessus
on sait jamais si c'est vrai ou pas que
le lama trash eh ben je vais vous dire
j'ai trouvé le mec qui a la réponse
regarde on vous confirme donc le lama
crash c'est sur les atteint un certain
sens la famille castaldi
je veux le chien et le chat je vous
avais montré cette vidéo regardez c'est
le chien qu'un petit problème gastrique
comme benjamin et il énerve fortement le
chat c'est la roue des positions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque une petite tape comme ça c'est
exceptionnel
j'ai l'impression que les singes ont un
problème avec leur cul cul je voulais
vraiment c'est en 10e position
les singes pour moi c'est les vidéos les
plus drôles un sage regarder celle là de
ne voir là ce pas trop rigoler mais on
dirait que le mec a dit le sage fait un
sketch on dirait qu'il est sur scène
c'est un truc de ouf
non mais franchement je suis fan et
sympa voilà je vous le dis je sais pas
pour vous mais je suis fan dans le top
10 les enfants c'est mignon ça adore les
animaux les amphores moi j'adore voilà
mes enfants ils veulent toujours aller
au zoo et parfois un rien leur fait peur
même une chèvre regarde le pommier
millions ça c'est mignon c'est rien en
huitième position c'est genre de vidéos
que je tique le kiff seller chaque essai
de sauter et en fait ils évaluent mal la
distance il vaut santé ici il ya deux
mètres mais en fait on fait qu'à 3 m non
nous regarde
[Musique]
le repos alors j'ai eu le chat au
téléphone je suis pas bien il va très
bien j'ai eu et il m'a dit voilà il m'a
dit franchement il va il va très bien
j'ai la même en septième position mais
avec un chat à la neige cette fois
regarder ces impositions si vous êtes à
table fait une pause tout à l'heure on a
eu un chat qui frappait le chien après
une petite là tu lances et main là c'est
autre chose
6e
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça il est dégoûté le pô ville un peu
plus il se dit pourquoi ils habitent
avec moi de gala allez on rentre dans le
top 5 des images drôles des animaux
puisque vous savez on a fait on aime le
président de la spa guerlain ce temps
imagine tu es un gorille tu es dans ton
dos et tu te fais un petit peu tu
t'ennuies un peu paient donc qu'est ce
que tu fais si on te donne une piscine
et bains ce même site et un gorille tu
profites tu profites regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère
[Musique]
et il est excellent quand tu vois il est
excellent mais je le trouve beau gosse
je le trouve beau renault se trouve
pause gorille allez on rentre dans le
top 4 pendant le confinement il ya une
djette qui voulait faire semblant de
mixer mais le problème c'est que le chat
qui est à côté
il a eu une angoisse et celi franchement
c'est une catastrophe
regardez c'est pas david guetta regain
pas là me faire
[Musique]
[Rires]
la numéro quatre est folle alors on va
rentrer dans le top 3 des vidéos des
animaux qui nous ont fait marrer ya
plein de gens sur internet qui me disent
on se doute qu'elle est la première je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas tort donc sonné
au 033 je vous faire baver sur la
meilleure boulangerie c'était sur m6 il
ya quelques années c'était un chat qui
se prenait une porte
regardez bien en bas à droite regardez
bien celle ci nous a fait mourir de
regarder quelle surprise la seconde
boulangerie du jour réservé d'hôtel à
notre jury
[Musique]
la réponse dans le charmant village de
saint céré vous l'avez loupé à porte
c'est très très furtif 1 voilà le pauvre
mais j'ai eu le choix il va bien il a
fait des baguettes tout va bien en
numéro 2 je vous dis elle est
extraordinaire on connaît tous des potes
qui sont des grosses balance voilà qui
voit là les poux caf de ouf
alors déjà je vous le dit qu'il ira sera
dès qu'il ira sera le cas il vous
balance dès qu'un truc qui va pas il
balance il pour calvin tous vos potes
tout ça alors qui a mangé la saucisse je
vous pose la question qui a mangé la
saucisse regardez bien le tiennent
debout qui est pris à la volée dans
garrigue aux ondines à dieu elle est
aimée chez vous je vien de nou ce soir à
prix des biens belles âmes à 1
c'est qui c'est toi olga ses fruits
et toi et moi c'est qui
ça va ça va et moi qui applique un frigo
c'est génial
elle est là est génial et le fait de la
peine le petit coup de tête à la fin
c'est horrible tout message fait trop de
peine sans rigoler bien entendu vous
cherchez sur ses amis qui ont amis
numéro un
bien sûr c'est ma préférée de tous les
temps de toutes les vidéos du monde
c'est bien sûr le singe et la mamie le
singe qui cède son caca
je peux l'avoir d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
gelé vue je pense au moins un million de
fois ce mois-ci seul déjà regardé on la
revoit pour le kit est là je la lance et
j'ai déjà envie d'avoir
[Musique]
m c'est la meilleure entre un vieux
monsieur qui croquera je vis ça c'est
sûr et certain mathieu même mathieu la
voulait qu'on leur doit alors la mort
alors voila voila moi c'est la numéro 1
la voie pour le kiff c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'énorme d'arca voilà team de cette
vidéo